what's good this is ck check me out on
the bootleg kev podcast keep it locked
yo it's the boulet cavs show we got a
special guest in here international
superstar i got one of the hottest
records uh in the world right now
one of my favorite songs one of them
songs that comes on and just gets you
this makes you feel good man we got the
homie ck in here welcome man i'm good
what's going on how are you doing bro
i'm all right what's what's going on you
good it's crazy because you've been
doing your thing for a long time but
like to finally catch like one of them
ones that crosses over in the united
states yeah how does that feel man
i mean it feels good you know um
love wanted
really special song you know like people
from different ethnicities and languages
you know connect so heavy with the song
you know and it feels good to see that
happen no for sure people love the
record it's just a feel-good song give
me the back story of the record how old
is the song too because sometimes songs
will become hits and we won't know they
might be two or three years old yeah i
mean i made love wanting to 2019
um
i think it came out around august on my
ep ck the first and it was track two
um
then we released the video the music
video for the first remix in
february 2020
you know
that was like the first moment it had in
nigeria and africa it was already big in
africa
then like in 2021 it came back again you
know and like this time
it was like global you know literally
every country on earth
so it's like it's like a legit like two
and a half year old song something like
that yeah and what was for you like did
you notice like a moment or something
that happened that kind of
gave it that that the last run it's been
on what was it yeah so it was um
so when i released it i had an acoustic
version
on my youtube
so um
in 2021 a dj from mauritius
his name is dj yo so he took that
acoustic version and he put drums on it
and i don't know one thing that's one
thing and it ended up on tick tock
and it just went crazy you know like
ridiculous it was a bootleg it was a
bootleg remake yeah yeah it wasn't even
official like we didn't even know about
the remix until you know it it went
viral and we had to find the dj you know
where was he at but i'm just wondering
this is mauritius oh so like who is dj
you what's his i didn't even know his
instagram i was i was looking for his
instagram you know
and like you know um when we finally
found him
and my team reached out to like you know
reclaim the record literally the next
day
it became number one on shazam global
and it was number one for like
two three months straight his version
yeah
wow so yeah so basically that version
was like uh
like a catalyst out there
that kind of led all the other versions
to going crazy too and is that the
version we hear on american radio
actually the version on american radio
is the original the og version the og
version but like
yeah mostly on on tick tock instagram
that's the remake it was it was that dju
version did we cut djo in absolutely
okay just to make sure we got to take
care of that guy absolutely
yeah that's a like life-changing moment
for him too i'm sure of course um
for people who like how long have you
been making music because you know i
feel like the afrobeat wave has been
huge for a long time but it's finally
kind of getting his moment here in the
states commercially but how long have
you been at it man
man um
since i was like 13 i've been writing
songs you know
but like not not not officially or not
like releasing music yeah
i've seen releasing music since like
2016
17. so it's been a minute yeah
but like i would say my first
major release was in 2019 with my ep ck
the first it was like my first official
ep and is that the ep that had love
yeah wow okay
damn man so it's been a journey yeah it
has um give me kind of like in in your
opinion like when you come to the states
and you kind of see the reaction to like
some of your music based on like
you know i feel like
the wave is a little bit newer here as
to where in nigeria or even in the uk i
feel like they've been hit to like what
y'all been doing for a very long time
like is there a difference between doing
a
a show in the u.s and maybe doing a show
back home or doing a show in the uk
you know what's crazy like
right now
i think it's all the same thing you know
because
i just did my first show in new york
like a week ago
uh and people told me that like
you know american crowds are very
uptight you know they are well they are
just so you know they are yeah so that
we're spoiled [ __ ] over here yeah
but that's that's the thing though like
my experience hasn't been tells me
differently okay okay because the the
crowd i performed for in nigeria in
london in new york in puerto rico it's
literally all been great energy
you know i can't even really tell you
the difference because like everyone
just vibes with the music so heavy
and like it doesn't even matter where
you're from
if i'm performing on stage i feel like
i'm in i could be anywhere because the
energy is always there there you know so
yeah i'm really really really happy to
see that
you know i'm really happy to to
meet good energy
here and like you know i've been in the
studio as well
with a bunch of great people and the
vibes i've just have you been in the
studio with
um i was in the studio with uh diplo
last night nice yeah we made we made
something real shout out to diplo yeah
he's really cool guy man and uh yeah we
made something real crazy
and uh lots more man
lots more
is there going to be a i don't know
maybe i might be stupid here i might
know but there's not a remix like an
official like remix because you know i
saw fireboy put out the remix of ed
sheeran and then
we had the essence remix like i feel
like it's only natural i know you
dropped a new single but i know that
i'm sure a lot of people have wanted to
hop on this record
yeah i mean
yeah like
lots of people wanted to do love wanting
to remixes
but like i actually turned down a lot of
them because i mean i can't remix one
song with the whole industry
i mean like that would be nice but like
yeah i just felt like
in terms of remixing and
all that stuff for me it's it's more of
a vibe thing it's not like always a
commercial movie like not go chase the
big name yeah like
the big names are great and everything
and i'm i'm very open to working with
the big names and everyone else as long
as there is a vibe you know it'll make
no sense to to make music or do
something with someone who has
you know let's say a billion streams if
in reality so you turned down justin
bieber for the remix i never said that
but like just say like if if if we meet
like face to face and we have a sit down
like you and i are having right now and
there's no connection why are we gonna
do the remake nothing matters anymore
because like you know even if even if
it's one stream you have and there's a
connection
you you know two artists could make a
song that could change the whole world
you know would you say we have a
connection because i have one stream
and we could do a remix we're connecting
right now yeah there it is
so you turned down you pretty much
turned down everybody who was trying to
tap in well no no i'm sure the label too
was probably trying to bring you like
hey we should do the remix you know it
feels like the label type of thing to do
it feels like the dwight willis type of
thing to do
yeah
but yeah i mean for me i'm just
i'm just trying to make new stuff you
know i'm working on my first album right
now
it's coming out this year really excited
about the album
um with my music i like to push sonic
boundaries i like to try new things i
feel like
if i'm making music
and it sounds exactly like
what my predecessor has made there's
literally no points in me making music
so i like that
yeah i always like to
to do something extra you know do
something different and to just make a
vibe that people can feel you know
because afrobeats is very
rhythm centric you know but my style of
afrobeats which i call emo afrobeats is
like
it's heavier on the rhythm but it's like
also heavy on the emotions too and the
vibes because like i want people to feel
stuff when they listen to my emo afro
beats yeah i like that
did you ever listen to like emo music
and absolutely like what would we
consider emo music because i think i'm
from a different generation than you
quite possibly
like out here there's like rock bands
that we consider emo like uh
i really like paramore i feel like they
have that's emo yeah yeah yeah actually
paramore is incredible yeah heavy with
paramore's music i think
that's literally my favorite band
they're incredible you know um i also
used to listen to lots of juice world
juice world triple
yeah so like this this is literally my
stuff that's a nemo rap for sure mm-hmm
and it's like my favorite you know i
listen to triple x like
an unhealthy amount of times you know
when you listen to like because i always
feel like um you can't help but be
influenced when you're a fan of somebody
like that like would you consider
yourself to be influenced by someone
like x who who was here for such a short
amount of time but his music had such a
big impact i would say a little bit yeah
cause
i don't know because he's a pisces and
i'm a i'm a pisces moon
so i don't know i feel like i connect
with his music on a crazy level yo we
got to stop the interview real quick and
tell you about our partners at odd socks
watch this i bet you i got socks on
right [ __ ] now
oh yeah see them bad boys these are what
we call the odd socks basics the ankles
the ankle socks right go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
put the website up promo codes bootleg
cab you're gonna save 20 off at checkout
they got so many crazy ass socks we got
twizzlers [ __ ] halloween
uh
i mean these are kind of satanic it just
says demon
they were like let's just do a generic
demon sock
i mean this is kind of like uh
i guess like if you were in the 80s in
miami doing cocaine off of a stripper's
[ __ ]
jaws pepsi i mean listen breaking bad
nickelodeon keep going but what's most
important is odd socks is our family
look if you support odd socks you
support the bootleg cat podcast so go to
bootleg kev well you can go to
bootleghead.com and just check it out
but you could also go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev and save
20 off at checkout do that [ __ ] right
now all right let's get into the uh
interview that we've already been inside
of but we're gonna get back to it right
now
if you had are you familiar with uh
mount rushmore here in the united states
with the four presidents
yes so if you had to give me the mount
rushmore of afrobeats who's on it
wow
um
i mean this is really easy i mean
david dewey's kid bona boy
and me and you i like that
he put himself on there as he should as
he should
you know who i met that was super nice
um
i'm gonna [ __ ] his name up so forgive me
because i know i'm going to [ __ ] his
name up
is it
or omg
i [ __ ] it up
um
you know what i'm saying
yeah um yes super nice guy yeah he's
cool someone said he was like a super og
in like the afro beats world
that's what i'm talking about
so i i didn't [ __ ] it up as bad as i
thought
oh wow wow that's what you were trying
to say that's what i was trying to say i
i knew i was going to [ __ ] it up i
[ __ ] up what i meant i need to teach
you now
yes that's it okay yeah that's a that's
a og for sure he's a legend
um it's it's dope too because like i
feel like you know having like almost
like a genre that
you know when we think of like the us
hip hop's been around forever
um
you know rock pop music all this [ __ ]
has been around for so long and it just
feels good to like have a whole new
genre of music kind of take over the
country like you know it happened with
reggaeton you know maybe like 15 years
ago
and with afrobeat it feels like so many
commercial artists are like heavily
influenced now by what you guys are
doing like i mean drake you know drake
one dance you know what i mean like that
was how many years ago was one dance
i was like
five years ago yeah
wizkid was on it yeah
yeah but
like you guys have so much influence now
just over just like the artists here
like just over pop music in general like
do you guys do you feel that when you
listen to some of the commercial music
that isn't necessarily
from where you're from like you do you
hear the influence you guys are having
on absolutely like
i always say this i feel like afrobeats
is
quickly becoming the new pop
you know because it's like
pop music is literally
music that everyone likes you know of
course and pop music is not a specific
genre so we might just be witnessing pop
just means popular exactly so we might
be witnessing a shift kodak black super
gremlin is pop music right now
for the record yeah so i feel like we're
witnessing a shift in pop music and like
the fact that in such a short time this
music that came from africa is having
such an influence here and like even in
the uk not just here like in in europe
in
you know
south america even latin artists are
loki
you know we're having like a
i don't know like an overlap
of sonics and culture right now and i
think it's it's really amazing you know
if you could do um a collab project with
someone because we've been seeing a lot
of artists do whole albums together
whole eps together who would you do a
collab project with if you could have
your choice
um
billy eilish billy eilish yeah nice
i heard she's super nice i've never met
her but i heard she's a sweetheart i
heard too i think she makes great music
emo and i think we would actually make
fire songs like it's not just because of
the
you know
the biz the numbers or whatever like
like they'd be big like i told you like
i mean i care about all that stuff but
like at the end of the day like i really
care about the music yes of course the
end product yeah so like i feel like
musically it's gonna make sense billy
island should be big let's just be clear
you're not turning down a drake remix
are you
because that'd be crazy remix to what
though
you're you're single like if drake you
said you turned down all these big
artists for who wanted to reach out but
you wouldn't turn down drake remix in
the record right
i would just i mean that would to me
that'd be the one where like i don't
know if i i've never even met you i'm
absolutely open to making a record like
if drake slides in your dms and you guys
don't have that bonding moment and he
just sends you a remix
yeah you gotta kind of run with that
just say [ __ ] the relationship let's get
these numbers you know
that that'd be a moment
yeah he said no i want to hang out with
drake first make sure we're the same
kind of guy make sure we get along
yeah i think take him for some coffee
and maybe that would actually make more
sense you know no i wouldn't make it
because
what's crazy is like i've in my own
space i've done collaborations that
were like set up that we're like you
know
engineered collaborations and i've done
collaborations that were like
organic based on vibes and like i know
the difference there's a big difference
here there's always a difference like
regardless of numbers regardless of
anything like
that connection is so important because
music is you know i think music is
spiritual you know as much as it's
melodies and all that stuff like
it's
it's an it's artists really speaking
their truth on beats so like
when there's a connection it's a
completely different ballgame yeah we
got to stop the interview right now uh
listen man i got to say about blue too
our good folks at blue chew one of our
sponsors for the podcast and a product
that i use all right now everyone thinks
that you know maybe
taking a product like blue chew which
has the same active ingredients as
cialis and viagra is a thing it's not a
thing it's very normal you might have
anxiety you might have stress you need
that confidence to get your [ __ ] on
alright trust me
you want to lay thor's hammer down on
that puss you know what i'm saying or
that butthole whatever you're into
let me tell you something best part
about blue chew not only is it in a
chewable form but you know when we think
about going to the doctor's office and
getting um a prescription for something
like this
we think about it as a maybe an
embarrassing conversation to have an
awkward conversation to have well
bluechu is an online prescription
service there's no visits to the
doctor's office that's right it ships
right to your door in a discrete package
and when i tell you blue chew helps you
if you're a man
achieve a harder and stronger erection
believe me when i say bud it's the
[ __ ] truth all right it helps men
combat all forms of ed all right and let
me tell you if you're getting ready to
go on a date
you just want to impress a young lady
you got to pop that blue chew man that
have your dick
you it might add a half an inch to your
dick your dick's never bits hard in your
[ __ ] life
i mean serious ain't being serious yo
even if you just want to jerk off and
just be like yo this is nice
it's [ __ ] amazing so go over to blue
chew it is a chewable tablet you don't
have to swallow it no pills nothing like
that bluetooth licensed medical
providers they work with you they find
the right ingredient and the right
strength for your prescription it's so
easy you go to bluetooth.com consult
with their licensed medical providers
and use the promo code bootleg put it on
the screen bootleg at checkout all you
got to do is pay five dollar shipping
and they're going to give you your first
month of bluetooth for free
that's right you can try bluetooth for
free go to bluechew.com use the promo
code bootleg and receive your first
month free
man oh man i am a user of the blue chew
and i [ __ ] with a shot shout out to
blue chew let's get back to the
interview i'm wondering um
what shows do you do you like binge
watch any tv shows cause i know in
different countries you guys have
different netflixs
nah i think it's pretty much the same no
it's not because y'all go to a different
country and i'll log into netflix and
there'll be all kinds of disney movies
that are in theaters and [ __ ] they'd be
lit on netflix in other countries i'm
like what the [ __ ]
i got to get a vpn
but um what what are like some of your
favorite shows like what do you what do
you like to watch man
um
i've not been watching much much tv
lately not gonna lie because i've been
crazy busy but um when you're not busy i
watched uh money heist is one of my
favorites great show um
gotta watch it with subtitles
yeah
the tinder swindler that was their
tender
yeah my enemies are after me and [ __ ]
i need like 200k bro like my enemies
they're trying to kill me you know the
tinder swindler thing is insane bro that
was like
bro
it's crazy that was insane um which
other one
uh there's this show called
um outer banks
i've heard outer banks yeah yeah
i think it was really interesting
um just to name a few have you ever
watched breaking bad
yeah i have but like i never finished it
it's amazing you know
like everyone around me
watches it but like i don't know like i
started
but i couldn't finish you got to stick
with it the first season's a little slow
but it gets crazy yeah but it's a great
show though yeah for sure no i uh this
tinder swin like tinder is definitely uh
a wild a wild thing man it's wild yeah
it's like yeah i never did you ever i
never i never used tinder
i think i think i used it like
briefly but like years ago did you hook
up off of it
nah no are you sure
you didn't i just tried it because like
people were talking about the whole
thing so i'm like oh let me let me see
what's the go-to uh dating app in uh
nigeria
i don't even know because we we're not
really big on dating apps like
that people just slide in dms bro it's
all dm sliding dms old school
bros slide in the dm or in real life you
know because like we'd be going to
parties a lot so what's your whatsapp
because i know over there everyone uses
whatsapp yeah what's up everyone uses
whatsapp it's like our major theme yeah
it's crazy because over here we like
look down on people with green bubbles
really yes it's a this is a thing so
like in the united states if you have an
iphone and i have an android
and i text the iphone and it's a green
bubble like it's almost like you're a
secondary citizen
i swear to god this is a thing
uh i mean whatsapp is just it's just
like i got pressured into getting an
iphone so i would so i have both but
everywhere else most people have
androids and and they all are on
whatsapp and whatsapp is lit as [ __ ]
yeah most people in the u.s ain't on
whatsapp though
it's kind of crazy shout out to whatsapp
and you guys use audio mac a lot over
there right
we we use everything to be fair we use
audio mark we use apple music spotify
everyone just
picks what they're you know they're
comfortable with if you had to um
let's say i visit your home country what
is like the one
dish that you would make sure i had to
have while i was out there whether it's
at a specific restaurant or some home
cooking what's the dish man
right off the bat i would say uh
i'd say fried rice
okay how they said jello fries black
i think fried rice is more fun okay and
like uh
there's something called suya it's like
it's like a type of meat
it's like beef but it's like dipped in
some spicy sauce and stuff and it sounds
amazing it's roasted over like an open
fire wow and it's it's real spicy though
but you're gonna love it
while you're in la somebody needs to
take you to a taco truck
that's yes someone has to somebody you
gotta take him to leo's taco truck
you gotta get some carne asada some el
pastor
you gotta tap in with some of this
mexican food in l.a yeah i had hot tacos
in miami though no no no tacos in miami
that sounds like a terrible idea oh
really what
what no no no okay no i hear you that's
like saying you had
like lobster in oklahoma or something
like there's no water nearby that can
how fresh could it really be
yeah no you get while in cali you gotta
get real mexican food because it's the
best
yeah
not my when you're in miami you get
cuban food
or lobster no one told me [ __ ]
i lived in florida is the worst mexican
food ever it's terrible but yo we gotta
stop the interview real quick tell us
about uh i'm gonna tell you about our
partners in my bookie man make sure you
go to mybookie.ag right now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now just
go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're going to
give you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand to bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because yokitch is going to
[ __ ] pound them in their ass probably
great odds on that one
anyway mybookie.js
my bookie just [ __ ] google the [ __ ]
my bookie use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit free money
free money up to a thousand dollars
let's get back to the interview uh hey
so your album is coming how soon man
real soon this year for sure but like
you know i'm not i'm not really a huge
fan of giving dates
before the end of the year
yeah before the end of the year for sure
um but yeah i'm really excited about the
album and uh yeah i've got lots of
collaborations and stuff coming in
between lots of surprises what um
percentage would you say you're done
with the project
i can't see can't say not even fifty
percent done the twenty-five percent
done
you've got four
100 done for oh you know
or 20. i mean you were just in with
diploma 85
diplo that's got to make the album
yeah but it's what if it's his song
what's like that studio session like
with diplo because he's a very uh
eclectic guy fun guy to be around he is
and he's so talented he's got so many
different like um
i guess creative vibes he could tap into
you know diplo is really cool like um
i would say he's just like a free spirit
you know like um
we met in miami actually
and um yeah man he's just really chill
you know like i was really comfortable
working with them you know
good vibe in the studio did he offer you
any shrooms
no
i just had
good vibe in the studio you know great
energy great music you know great energy
great great guy well we can't well
hopefully it's it's it's coming out
either but on your [ __ ] or his [ __ ]
um you got the new single out right now
yes i do um it's called emiliana um i
just dropped a video like a week ago
going crazy
um yeah man i've got lots of more stuff
coming too
big collapse
some big collapse
okay
there it is man well listen i appreciate
you pulling up um go get the uh well the
new videos out go stream that is that
we got more music coming um anything
else you got that you're working on are
you working on like anything else that
you want the fans to know about
um
i'm also performing like uh
at a whole bunch of festivals and stuff
this year
um i'm doing the roots picnic in philly
that's gonna be fire yeah and like yeah
a whole lot more um roots picnic is a
movie yeah i heard lots of people told
me and yeah lots of stuff man you're
gonna see i don't like to say everything
i'm gonna do you know cause i you just
like to i like surprises you know yeah
you gotta watch the walk sometimes you
don't talk to talk you gotta walk the
walk yeah what's life without surprises
so like um
yeah i've got lots of stuff coming just
stay tuned stay tuned ck hey why don't
you introduce your new single for us man
i so ladies and gentlemen this is
emiliana brand new single
fresh off the oven fresh out of the oven
bootleg kev show boom